>> Will: ANOTHER SAD EXAMPLE
OF SOFT ON CRIME IN LIBERAL
CITIES AND ONCE AGAIN OUT WEST,
THE LOW LIFE WHO PLOWED HIS CAR
INTO A GROUP OF 75 LOS ANGELES
POLICE RECRUITS IS NOW FREE AS A
BIRD DESPITE THE FACT THAT
POLICE CALLED INJURING 25 CADETS
A "DELIBERATE ATTACK".
THE 22-YEAR-OLD DRIVER WAS
ARRESTED ON CHARGES OF ATTEMPTED
MURDER OF A POLICE OFFICER BUT
DEPUTIES LET HIM GO BECAUSE
INVESTIGATORS SAID THEY NEED
MORE TIME TO PRESENT THEIR CASE
TO THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY WHO
MUST FILE CHARGES WITHIN 48
HOURS AFTER AN ARREST OR RELEASE
THE SUSPECT.
JESSE, YOU FIRST.
>> Jesse: I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY HE'S OUT.
WHY WOULDN'T THEY CHARGE HIM ON
A NO BAIL COUNT OR SEEK NO BAIL
BECAUSE NOW HE'S OUT AND THESE
CADETS ARE ALL LOSING LIMBS AND
NOW IN CRITICAL CONDITION.
IT SENDS THE WRONG MESSAGE AND
HE WASN'T DRUNK SO WHY WAS HE
PURPOSELY TARGETING HIS CAR
AGAINST POLICE?
SOUNDS LIKE A WAR ON COPS AND
DOESN'T SURPRISE ME THIS IS
HAPPENING IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AND TONIGHT ON JESSE WATTERS
PRIME TIME WE'LL HAVE THE
SHERIFF FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY
ONTO EXPLAIN WHAT THE HELL IS
HAPPENING HERE.
THIS ISN'T GOOD AND I'M WAITING
FOR DEMOCRATS TO SAY SOMETHING
BECAUSE DURING THE ELECTION, WE
HEARD ABOUT HOW MUCH THEY LOVE
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THAT'S ALL YOU HEARD.
THEN THE MINUTE THE ELECTION
ENDS, SOMEONE TRIES TO KILL 25
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS AND NO
ONE EVEN MAKE AS STATEMENT ABOUT
THIS.
THIS IS A PRETTY BIG STORY.
>> Will: JUDGE, THEY'RE
CALLING IT A DELIBERATE ATTACK.
ARE THEY HAVING TROUBLE GETTING
INTO HIS MIND TO SHOW IT WAS
INTENTIONAL?
>> Jeanine: I SPOKE TO THE DAS
TODAY AND THEY COULD HAVE
CHARGED HIM WITH A CRIME.
THAT CRIME WOULD HAVE BEEN A
BAILABLE OFFENSE.
WHAT THEY'RE DOING IS THEY'RE
PUTTING TOGETHER THE EVIDENCE TO
SEE HOW FAR THEY CAN GO.
THEY'RE VERY ETHICAL AND YOU'RE
NOT FINDING DAS SAYING WE'RE
GOING TO GET THEM.
LOOK AT WHAT HE DID.
NO, THEY'RE LISTENING TO THE LAW
AND ANALYZING THE LAW.
I LOVE THE SHERIFF AND THINK
HE'S A GREAT GUY AND STATUTES
ARE CLEAR AND THEY HAVE TO KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE DEALING WITH IN
TERMS OF THE DRIVER BEFORE THEY
CAN CHARGE.
IT'S UNLIKELY FOR ME TO TAKE
THIS STANCE, YOU KNOW IT.
>> Jesse: IS IT ATTEMPTED
MURDER OR WHAT IS IT?
>> Jeanine: DEPENDS ON WHETHER
THEY CAN ATTRIBUTE THAT TO HIS
INTENT OR HIS CONDITION.
WE'RE NOT SAYING BECAUSE WE
DON'T KNOW.
LET IT GO.
>> Harris: THE REPORTS WERE
THAT HE WAS CHARGED WITH
ATTEMPTED MURDER OF A PEACE
OFFICER AND RELEASED LATER THAT
NIGHT AT 9:49 P.M..
G THERE'S NO CHARGE RIGHT NOW.
>> Harris: RIGHT.
>> Jeanine: THEY DROPPED THE
CHARGE BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
HAVE --
>> Harris: DOES THAT AFFECT
THE CASE LONG TERM BECAUSE YOU
DIDN'T HAVE --
>> Jeanine: NO, THE POLICE CAN
MAKE AN ARREST AND THE DA SAYS
YAY OR NAY TO THE CHARGE AND
POLICE CAN COME IN TILL THE COWS
COME HOME WITH ATTEMPTED MURDER
AND DA SAYS YOU DON'T HAVE IT.
WE DON'T HAVE THE EVIDENCE, YOU
FINISH THE INVESTIGATION, WE'LL
GO FOR IT.
THERE'S NO CHARGE NOW.
>> Will: SO, JESS TO YOU AND
JUDGE JUMP ON, LOOKING AT LOS
ANGELES AND IF YOU'RE A LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY, YOU FEEL
LIKE YOUR BURDEN IS MUCH HIGHER
THAN IN THE PAST.
IF YOU SEND SOMETHING ONTO
GEORGE GASCON AND HIS OFFICE AND
DON'T HAVE TS CROSSED AND IS
DOTTED, DON'T EXPECT A VIGOROUS
PROSECUTION?
>> I FIRST WANT TO SAY I'M GLAD
YOU WENT TO THE JUDGE BEFORE ME,
WHICH I REALLY SAY BUT IT WAS
GOOD BACKUP AND IT WAS A CENTRAL
ISSUE IN THE LA MAYOR'S RACE
THAT GOT CALLED AND RICK CARUSO
RUNNING THIS TIME AROUND AS A
DEMOCRAT PUT CRIME FRONT AND
CENTER AND KAREN BASS WON BUT
SHE SHIFTED HER MESSAGE ON CRIME
TO BE A MUCH MORE SERIOUS ABOUT
IT AFTER HAVING A BREAK IN
HERSELF.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I BELIEVE
MAYOR ELECT BASS WILL BE TAKING
SERIOUSLY.
I THINK THINGS WILL CHANGE, EVEN
THOUGH I KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF DISAPPOINTMENT, MORE ON THE
RIGHT THAN LEFT BUT SOME
DEMOCRATS ABOUT POSTELECTION
MESSAGING THAT THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF, OH, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
DO ANYTHING DIFFERENTLY.
HERE IN NEW YORK WHERE I VOTED,
PEOPLE HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR WHAT
HAPPENED AND WE LOST FOUR
CONGRESSIONAL SEATS BECAUSE OF
LAW AND ORDER SEATS.
LEE ZELDIN PERFORMED WAY ABOVE
THAN WE'D EXPECT BECAUSE WE PUT
CRIME FRONT AND CENTER.
THERE'LL BE CHANGES.
>> Harris: I'M GLAD YOU USED
THE WORD SHIFT.
THEY TALKED ABOUT IT DEMOCRATS
LATE IN THEIR CAMPAIGN BECAUSE
GENERAL PSAKI, THE FORMER WHITE
HOUSE SECRETARY SAID THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT CRIME IN ALL THE
ADS AND IT'S KILLING US.
YOU GOT TO TALK ABOUT IT.
YEAH, THE PUNDITS ON THEIR SIZE
OF THE AISLE SAID IT'S ON FIRE
AND GET A HOSE.
THEY TALKED ABOUT IT BUT NOT IN
THE WAY THAT WAS SUBSTANTIVE IN
TERMS OF HOW DO YOU DEAL WITH
NOT LETTING PEOPLE GO ON CRIMES
THAT YOU KNOW THAT YOU CAN, YOU
KNOW, SIX MONTHS AGO WOULD HAVE
BEEN A FELONY AND THEY'RE A
MISDEMEANOR.
>> LOOK AT JOSH SHAPIRO, THE NEW
GOVERNOR OF PENNSYLVANIA AND
WENT AFTER DA KRASNER AND --
>> Harris: THAT'S TWO.
>> TWO PEOPLE ABLE TO WIN AND
JOSH SPA SHAPIRO GOT OVER
3 MILLION VOTES AND IT'S
HISTORIC.
>> Will: LEAVE IS HERE AND ALL
YOU HAVE